well Russia's president has promised to
supply free grain to several African
countries Vladimir Putin has welcomed
African leaders to an economic Forum in
Saint Petersburg the collapse of the
Black Sea deal on Ukrainian grain
exports is causing concerns in Africa
about Rising food prices as well as
shortages Putin is seeking to reassure
Africans that Russia is a reliable
partner
is
a share of the global wheat Market is 20
Ukraine is less than five percent this
means it is Russia that is making a
significant contribution of Global Food
security and is a big and responsible
supplier of agricultural Goods those who
claim that this is not the case and talk
of ensuring the so-called grain deal are
twisting the facts telling lies well
we'll speak to Malcolm Webb in the
Kenyan Capital Nairobi in just a moment
but first let's go to Ali Hashem he's
covering that Summit for us there in
Saint Petersburg Ali it feels like this
is quite the symbolic gesture there from
Putin
well yeah President Putin is right now
welcoming he he will welcome the
presidents of the 17 African countries
during this Summit earlier today and
mainly this Summit was about uh soothing
the African concerns over the uh the the
fall of the grains deal so now with this
um initiative from the Russian president
he's he's trying to
um set an example in a way or another in
the middle of a struggle for Africa we
all know that Russia is looking forward
to
secure its interests in the in the
continent and there is a struggle
between Russia China and the West over
the the continent so in this in this
Summit the Russians were trying to
provide this initiative and it seems
that there are other initiatives that
also Putin was trying to convey through
his speech on the technological side on
the energy side food security side if
you go around this uh
Forum there are many companies
showcasing their own material elements
equipments
agriculture military so it's kind of a a
an attempt by the Russians to reach out
to the Africans on the second time the
first time was around four years ago
about today it seems different
especially with number of African
leaders participating in the summit
around half the ones that participated
in
2019. interesting turn there in Saint
Petersburg Ali Hashem at that conference
for us in Russia thank you well let's
get the view from Africa now and speak
to Malcolm Webb who joins us from
Nairobi Malcolm Kenya won't be getting
any of the free grain that's been
announced but food security has been a
huge issue on the continent exacerbated
by the war in Ukraine
well Kenya's president William Ruto
announced just a few days ago that he
wouldn't be attending the Russia Africa
Summit which takes place at a time when
Russia and the West are competing for
influence in Africa Kenya has
historically aligned itself with the
West ever since independence from
British colonial rule uh so possibly
that explains why it wasn't among the
beneficiaries but neighboring Somalia
was among the countries named by Putin
that will receive grain Somalia is
suffering a hunger crisis people are
dying following one of the worst
droughts in decades now in previous
years almost all of its grain Imports
have come from Ukraine and Russia about
two-thirds from Ukraine about a third
from Russia a lot of that grain goes
first to Egypt where it's milled before
it arrives in Somalia and the tens of
thousands of tons of grain that Putin
was talking about would make up a very
small proportion of the hundreds of
thousands of tons of grain that Somalia
depends on each year Malcolm what are
the biggest priorities then the African
leaders who've chosen to go to Saint
Petersburg what did they want to get out
of this
or grain and food security is a priority
for some high fruit prices across the
world in recent years have been
devastating for the least wealthy people
across the African continent and while
those people many of them live in
countries where they have no meaningful
way of holding their governments to
account hunger and a High Cost of Living
can cause unrest and instability and
threaten government's grips on power
here in Nairobi in recent weeks we've
seen protests against the High Cost of
Living people have been killed when
police have broken them up defense
access to Russian arms and Military
Support is also a a priority for some of
the governments there the leaders of
both Mali and the Central African
Republic are there both of those
countries were named by Putin as
recipients of grain and both of their
governments depend on the vat on the
Wagner mercenary group to provide
security for those governments to to
survive live
Malcolm Webb there in the Kenyan Capital
Nairobi for us thank you Malcolm